all right part two so we talked about
spy so how we felt about that now let's
deep dive as far as some other aspects
of the show Lord said what do you
actually what else would I mention about
the experience itself okay so some other
things about it
third party was week which I mean to be
fair they said it was going to be deep
dive so third party was not the focus
Kingdom Hearts 3 showed up yet again for
some reason okay cool revenues new game
control revealed I'm a remedy fanboy I'm
in one cool I'm with it this way looks
sweet yeah looks great looks like wanna
break ball don't lose them with it
Resident Evil 2 remake of anything on
any stream unchecked other streams and
our theater doesn't matter broad sounds
like you got freaked out did not yeah
okay look rest people to my favorite
Resident Evil games in the entire series
and Bravo that trouble when I can they
finally show that I was like yeah I'm
crazy
that's my heart the greatest thing
another phone story going back and forth
and then I calls on belladonna
trenchcoat dude this kid a broken hose
and put the feet of my absolutely so
ready to do was definitely heard I'm I'm
that's one of the first things I'm
playing tomorrow it's played on the
floor throw the brawls [ __ ] gonna get
next to the dog that was it well we got
next on the docket is no
backwards-compatibility nothing no one
say knows but they're expecting it but
there's a few insiders out there right
we're saying it was going to happen
no it's not stop fooling yours in new
boy station name changes we shall just a
meme at this point baby they're saving
it for PSX and I don't know but it's out
there nothing new about BS now nothing
new about PS Plus C so if Holly black
ops 3 ok well yeah we got the shadow
drop the box right there but other than
that it's like if you're looking for
improvement in the surfaces this day
wasn't that time you're not getting it
was a nighttime car and I'm so surprised
me destined to is also very short which
we met we met you know they got the
marketing credit I understand
destinies maybe but not in its highest
level places you know not our surprise
that I thought that they would use more
of the marketing deals I thought so too
I thought they were gonna show the
blackout so what do you wouldn't you
feel oh those points specifically just
on any any other things that maybe were
missing at you with things that weren't
there or neo2
down stole almost like 102 yeah there's
been a development so long to have the
sequel not ready all that they probably
they were probably working on the sequel
years like a couple of years ago when
they were working on the first game but
hey you know what new is cool
I still want to dive into it my brothers
are probably the biggest neo fanboys in
the world they're going nuts blowing up
my phone with it's okay it's cool I know
that's a cool to know that III 2019 is
rise of Japan the game okay there's no
time twice neo to and go sumo there you
go
yeah I like a point listen I'm all about
you don't an old bird
so what we got to wrap this thing up
they say well the little guy when we got
left on a docket we got final scores to
give oh all right so if she got away you
know wait third party we got away first
party we got away presentation because
I'm gonna speak for all of us here a
little bit and someone slap me if I'm
wrong I think all the games look
fantastic at the end of the day death
stranding is a presentation there isn't
where I needed to be in terms of knowing
stuff about it but at the end of the day
the games all look great but we got away
this concrete that our entire console as
a condo really advertises a constant as
a conference we're sitting in 26.5 so
all the fancy conference me the way the
first presentation started in the first
30 minutes the west of us part 2 aside I
wanted to go to sleep
it was awful that then you broke up it
completely deflated the hype okay yes
has to be more to the elderly deflated
Heidi Soni please do not ever use that
format ever again 26 th was portrayed in
2017 was even a little too fast make
2016 was part of her yes yes I would
agree with that statement I'll give my
rating last but let's get the bra
because the bra only talked briefly off
learn and the presentation it was look
at this last it was to everyone we're
all excited we were talking about the
graphics gameplay now all of a sudden
well let's take a short break go outside
to our favorite play ship well guys oh
no I told you a few minutes ago a few
minutes ago but keep waiting for few
more minutes
No
what about them games don't what they
like people saying it's a present yeah
I can't microsoft's presentation did you
give myself hey okay yeah you know
playstation i can go back home nor it
sorry guys but mark saw had to bring the
they have to somebody had to they had to
confirm to the friends friends interface
they were in this the long run than they
did Sony Microsoft did man
new studios new exclusives entitles the
future for Xbox well sir that's what I
was really impressed on what they show
so why the presentation that was
everything started off yet averaging the
to bring them just breathe
I feel what you saying you know I'm
gonna cut you a quick finish well no I
think the game looks great the game is
gonna be great and I was the games you
really did it for me but the
presentation 34 it's just I think I
think I'm a grown this I mean I feel you
where you're at with this it was there
and they were positive a while rolling
my eyes I'm not gonna say the possible
role on the games are strong we knew
coming in what the forward right so I'm
like okay but here's my being just what
you said is we were promised deep dives
what I'm here deep dive I expect you
know it'll be the dev to come on you get
some level design stuff talking like it
just felt like extended trailers of what
was existing
and nobody warms things look phenomenal
what do you think I gotta cut you off do
you think that's indicative of where
three of them are experiments coming out
a couple more packages the other three
do you think that's indicative of these
games might not be twenty
ready and that's fine no it's fine that
plan is when you tell me deep dive I
expect you know a level of intricacy
with the presentation of what's supposed
to be shown it did have the developers
after the show went off the head
insomniac should see where the show yeah
it's still part of the presentation
though but it wasn't sure that
experience I got absolutely well have
some experience it just ended yeah it
was almost like a play yeah literally
felt like a live show PlayStation
experience they brought by the man out
again they show some other stuff and
that was cool but it getting sucide for
me
this is e3 right now I know they the
people gonna see but they told you it's
just I don't like this format I really
do I think so can't be exercised enough
yeah I think so it's the best
presentation theatrical show there's too
much I just felt it the music's stopped
like they got you know Jimmy coming out
with a bit okay cool they knew that that
authentic Japan you know okay you know
it was just a little bit over the top a
little bit too much with that but I
thought the game strong enough for me
personally goes to Shima was my star I
knew last ones company was gonna be what
it kind was gonna be overall I'm with
you bro I gave it a 7
no I gave it a 7 I felt like I said it
was definitely you know some high points
it was just a little uneven a certain
point but absolutely strong from this I
hope they will and I gotta say one last
thing before we close yeah come on that
from software tees at the end yeah don't
don't have more game from that name has
those replicas they go bad you got like
Nixon brought in the building witness
bomb people find you on twitter at
PlayStation brawl and of course my web
site the places in bras comm check it
out all the PlayStation will ever need
baby yeah and of course Lord Sam Nord
you can find me on Twitter at Samuel
taulbert happy to talk games and movies
in tech with you check out our website
tic games Network we cover games tech
reviews opinions we got it all all right
Laura anyway I love podcast well